[Müzik]
bir başka doğum hikayesi Benim Hikayem
ve kızlarımın hikayesi karından değil
kalpten doğuran bir anneyim ben ve kan
bağıyla değil cam bağıyla aile olmayı
öyküsü bizim öykü'müz bilinenden çok
farklı normal algılananın dışında ve
bilinmediği için de aslında korkulan bir
hikaye benim hikaye
altın Mart 2014 tarihinde bir çarşamba
günü saat tam 11'de Ankara'da
Keçiören'de bulunan Atatürk çocuk
yuvasından içeriye girdim ve bir daha
hayatım Asla eskisi gibi olmadı bir gün
önce telefonla aranmıştık ve telefondaki
ses koruyucu aileliğimizin başvurumuzun
kabul edildiğini ertesi gün bizi
beklediklerini söylüyordu çok
heyecanlıydı Elbette bizim için Çünkü
ben bir çocuğun hayatına dokunmak üzere
Anne olmak üzere oraya gidiyordum
o güne kadar 44 yaşındaydım yoğun bir iş
hayatım vardı Bir Köy Çocuğu olan ve çok
büyük zorluklarla inşaat mühendisi
olmayı başaran şirket Kuran ve giderek
büyüyen bir şirketin yöneticisi olan
Babamla birlikte çalışıyordum bu yoğun
iş hayatının içerisinde biyolojik çocuk
sahibi olmak da hiçbir zaman önceliğim
olmamıştı ve ben Elbette başarılı ve
mutlu olmaktan dolayı
kendimi iyi hissediyordum bireysel
Konfor alanımın içerisinde iyiydim Ancak
her gün o yoğun çalışma hayatından eve
döndüğümde yaşı başımı yasağı koyduğumda
ben bu hayata bunun için gelmiş olamam
diyordum kendi kendime çünkü bende eksik
olan bir şey vardı Tamamlanmamış bir
şeyi ve ben hayatımın anlamını arıyordum
aslında
Hani bir yapboz olur ya bu yapbozun
birkaç parçası eksik olduğu zaman tam
gözükmez o yapbozdaki manzara İşte ben
öyle hissediyordum kendimi eksik bir
şeyler vardı hayatımda Çünkü ben ben
olmayı biliyordum ancak biz olmayı
bilmiyordum
Atatürk çocuk yuvasından İçeriye
girdiğimde Önce bahçe beni büyüledi
kocaman yemyeşil bir bahçeydi etrafta
tarihi eserler vardı şaşırdım Allah
Allah dedim ne ki bunlar
Fuat bey Birinci Dünya Savaşı'nda
özellikle korunma ihtiyacı olan çocuklar
için çok önemli çalışmalar yapmış ve
himaye etfali Yani bizim bildiğimiz
ismiyle ve sonradan değiştirilen ismiyle
çocuk esirgeme kurumunu kurmuştu o
dönemde çocuklar için önemli çalışmalar
yapmış pullara çocukların resimlerine
bastırmış bağışlar toplamış ve hatta 23
Nisan fikrine Atatürk'e kendisi vermişti
soyadı kanunu çıktığı zaman da Atatürk
Fuat veya Umay soyadını uygun görmüştü
işte Umay pavyonu Fuat Bey'in soyadını
taşıyan binaydı
Fuat Umay bütün maddi sahibi olduğu her
şeyi bağışlamıştı ancak İsmet İnönü'nün
önerisiyle bu iki katlı o dönemde
yapılan ve O dönemin en büyük çocuk
koruma Yuvası olan Atatürk çocuk
yuvasına o binaya verilmesine izin
vermişti
Ben Asıl büyük şoku ve derin sarsıntıyı
o Umay pavyondan içeriye girdiğim zaman
yaşadım
0-3 yaş çocuklarının kaldığı bir binayı
da orası üst katta bebeklerin yattığı
karyolalar aşağı katta da çocukların O
çocukların oyun alanları vardı
İçeriye girdiğimde
onlarca çocuk etrafta oyun oynuyorlardı
hepsi birbirinden güzeldi şunu
hissettiğimi hatırlıyorum ne kadar
güzeller Çünkü çok şaşırmıştım bana
anlatılanlar öğrendiklerim ön yargılarım
toplumun bana
öğrettiği normal Bunlar değildi bunları
beklemiyordum
ve bakım verenler son derece Güler
yüzlüydü
etraf çok düzenliydi
fakat Asıl beni derinden sarsan şey
çocukların gözleriydi Çocukların gözleri
donuk bakıyordu
ben o gözlerdeki donuk ifade hiçbir
zaman unutmadım
ve sonradan öğrendim ki aslında
sevgisizlikmiş çocukların gözlerindeki
ifade sevgi ile sarılınmadığı zaman
Çocuklar iyi olmazmış
sevgisizlik Aslında çoğumuz bilmeyiz ama
en büyük şiddetmiş
güvenli bağlanamayan sevgiyle büyümeyen
her çocuk aslında Hayata son derece
eksik başlarmış
ben tabi bütün bunları çok daha sonra
öğrendim
müdüre Hanım'ın önüne oturdum bana dedi
ki kız çocuğu ve bebek istemişsiniz ülke
hanım evet dedim Çünkü yine öğrenmiş
öğrenmişliklerim
ve bana anlatılanlar ve bildiğim kız
çocuğu olursa benim olursa ve küçük
olursa bebek olursa çok daha kolay
olacak diyordu Oysa yine sonradan
öğrendim ki hangi yaşta ve Cinsiyette
olursa olsun hangi travmaya sahip olursa
olsun dokunulan her çocuk ilgi gören Her
Çocuk sevilen
ve travma döngüsü kırılırsa yoksulluk
döngüsü kırılırsa bir nesil değil
nesiller kurtulur işte koruyucu ailelik
bir nesne değil nesilleri kurtaran çocuk
koruma sisteminin en önemli
basamaklarından birisidir
ve bana dedi ki tanışmak ister misiniz
İki aylık bir bebeğimiz var adı Ela Evet
dedim isterim istemez miyim nasıl
istemem kızıma getirdiler pembe bir
battaniyenin içerisindeydi Hoca aldım
uyuyordu yüzü örtülüydü açtım çok güzel
bir bebekti çok güzel çok güzel dediğimi
ve çok ağladığımı hatırlıyorum
müdürüm çok deneyimliydi ve dezavantajlı
çocuklarla çok önemli çalışmalar
yapıyordu yıllardır bana dedi ki ülke
Hanım dedi bizim çocuklarımızın hepsi
çok güzeller bütün çocuklar Çok güzeller
ben Aslında oradaki o derin Manayı da
çok sonra anladım
Evet dedim gerçekten çok güzeller sonra
kızım gözlerini açtı
simsiyah gözleri vardı yine çok donuk
bakıyordu O da çok kısa bir süre önce
oraya teslim edilmiş olmasına ve koruma
altına alınmış olmasına rağmen
simsiyah çok güzel kirpikleri vardı
gözlerini açtı derin derin gözlerimin ta
içine baktı ve eşime dedim ki bana bir
şey anlatıyor Bu normal bir şey değil
Ben şimdi kızımın bana ne anlattığını
çok iyi biliyorum bana dedi ki anne dedi
çocuklar var
ihtiyaçları var
sevilmeye Biz seninle yeni bir yola
çıkıyoruz benden bize giden bir yola
çıkıyoruz bir seyahate başlıyoruz Hazır
mısın dedi bana
Biz kızımla Umay pavyonun önünde
fotoğraf çektirdik ve çıktık
yaklaşık bir hafta sonra bambaşka bir
çocuk vardı ve Ben kızımı doğurmadığımı
hatırlamıyordum gözleri Işıl ışıldı
gülüyordu ağlıyordu sesler çıkarıyordu
bu değişiklikle hepimiz çok şaşırıyorduk
Nasıl böyle bir şey olabilir diye Oysa
Bütün bunlar sevgiden ilgidenmiş
ve Ben kızımı doğurmadığımı
hatırlamıyordum İşte o zaman ben anladım
ki başkasının çocuğu diye bir çocuk
kavramı yok Her doğan çocuk hepimizin ve
her dokunulan çocuk iyileşiyor ya peki
diğer çocuklar ne olacak diye yola
çıktım
Fuat ummayın çocuk davası Artık benim de
çocuk davamdı kor ev Koruyucu aile
devlet edinme Derneği ile tanıştım o
güne kadar çok önemli çalışmalar
yapmışlardı ve 2016'dan beri de
arkadaşlarımla birlikte Öncelikle
koruyucu ailevi anlatmak bir başka doğum
hikayesini anlatmak kan bağıyla değil
ama Can bağıyla aile olmayı kalpten aile
olmayı anlatmak üzere yola çıktık ve
bütün çocukların çok sevildiği bir aile
ortamında olmaları için çalışıyoruz
ancak Tabi asıl önemli olan burada
Türkiye'de çocukla ilgili çok önemli bir
sorun var Çocuk muhtaç kavramı ile
eşleştiriliyor Oysa çocuk büyümekte olan
ve bizim ona eşlik ettiğimiz 18 yaşına
kadar uluslararası sözleşmelerle çocuk
olarak kabul edilen bir varlık bir birey
hiç kimsenin Aslında sahibi olduğu bir
varlık değil
Dolayısıyla Biz aslında çocukla ilgili
zihniyeti değiştirmek üzere çocuk
kavramının başka bir noktaya evrilmesi
için çalışıyoruz Her çocuğun iyilik
halinin sağlandığı ulusal Sürdürülebilir
kapsamlı bütüncül çocuk politikalarının
oluşturulması için çalışıyoruz Çünkü
biliyoruz ki aslında ülkenin geleceği
çocuklukta kurulur Eğer özellikle
öğrenim çağından önce ilk öğrenim
çağından önce çocuklar korunamazsa
maalesef ileri ki süreçlerde de o
çocuklardan başarılar elde etmek ve
ülkeyi Kurtarmak mümkün değildir
biliyor musunuz Atatürk de aslında bir
koruyucu babaydı ve evlat edinen bir
babaydı onlarca koruyucu ailesi olduğu
çocuğu ve evlat edindiği çocuğu vardı
hatta kızının ismini Ülkü diye kendisi
koymuştu kızlarımdan birisi Sinem Geçen
hafta Atatürk
Atatürk'ün önümüzdeki günlerde 10
kasım'ı anma töreni olacağı için okulla
birlikte Anıtkabir'e gitti ve bana
hediye olarak bunu almış
Çünkü benim çocuklarım Atatürk'ün çocuk
davasını
bugünlere kadar taşıyan ve bundan
sonrası için de
benim yol almamı sizlerin Yol almasını
anlatmam için bana yol açan çocuklar
aslında dinlersek bütün çocuklar çok
özeller Hepsi Bir iyiliği ve sevgiyi
yaymak için bu dünyaya geliyorlar
dünya eğer biz başkasının çocuğunu
seversek ve o Pamuklar içerisinde
koruduğumuz biyolojik çocuklarımızın
dışında başka çocukların da olduğunu ve
onlara dokunmasını gerektiğini anlarsak
iyileşecek benden bize doğru seyahat
edersek iyileşecek Ben Kızlarımla
tamamlandım İşte o bütün olan
bütünlendim ve o yapboz tamamlandı bugün
buraya kadar beni taşıdılar ve Benim
kızımın Sizinle bir resmini paylaşmak
istiyorum Ne zaman umutsuzluğa Düşsem ne
zaman birazcık yorulsam ne zaman
yeter dur desem ya da engellilerle
karşılaşsam böyle bana mesajlar
veriyorlar Her ikisi notlar bırakıyorlar
resimler yapıyorlar
ve diyorlar ki devam yola devam daha çok
kişiye anlatmalısın daha çok çocuk
sevgiyle buluşmalı daha çok insan anne
baba olmalı kızımın resmini sizinle
paylaşmak istiyorum
diyor ki kızım Duyduk duymadık demeyin
çocukların güvende olmasını istiyorsanız
biraz saygılı çocuklara İyi bakan birisi
olun
mutlu ve güzel bir ailede yaşıyorsanız
çok şanslısınız demektir Mesela ben öyle
mutlu olun zengin olmak sadece zengin
olmak değildir zenginlik iyi
davranılmasıdır evin içerisinde illaki
Can bağı da illaki kan bağı değil cam
bağı da olabilir Koruyucu aile
olabilirsiniz
beni dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür
ediyorum hepinize
[Müzik]